anyway i got one more in a different
space that i think sam will love
sean i told you about this book i read
about vertical farming and uh
you know basically like i read that wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
you guys just were talking about crypto
stuff and then he just said
i've got something i think sam will like
farming
yeah that big of a ready to you i like
it too
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want
all right we have a special guest on the
pod today fur khan is here he's my old
co-founder
uh probably the smartest guy i know uh
especially tech wise so we talked about
a bunch of things
ranging from his last company applovin
which just went public at a
20 30 billion dollar valuation so we
talked about
you know the humble beginnings of that
and all the way to a massive ipo
uh what he's doing with his money you
know so you win the lottery what are you
gonna do and he talks about his new
project
that he's building out and then we
talked about a bunch of cool things that
he
um he shows me so every
every week we do i do a call with him
called the cool [__] hour
where i just sit there on video and i
just say hey show me cool [__] that
you're interested in because he's
like a total uh you know tech nut he's
on the bleeding edge of everything
and so that's my hack to learn a bunch
of things before they go mainstream
and um so he talks about you know some
hardware stuff that he's really
interested in like a brain
wave measuring device that he's wearing
he talks about crypto
uh and then we talk about vertical
farming and the future of that
so a bunch of cool topics on that side i
would say there's some part of the
crypto stuff that might be
over your head so too many terms acronym
stuff you don't know about
here's my advice uh two ways you could
still get value even if you don't fully
get it because
hey i only half get it uh for con is
usually
10 steps ahead of me and so what i've
learned in knowing fergon for like
almost a decade now is
when he thinks something's interesting
instead of just saying i don't
understand that that's weird
uh lean in go google it later look it up
uh you know if i had just followed a
bunch of the things he was interested in
interested in i would have made a
killing
investment wise over the last decade and
i've learned the hard way that that's
what i should do
the second thing is uh he shared a bunch
of general advice about how he
went about his career you know college
dropout um
choosing jobs that weren't the highest
paying job and why he chose it what he
kind of optimizes for
i thought there was some good stuff in
there so if you are not subscribed to
this podcast if you're just listening to
this podcast maybe your friend told you
about it
you know what you need to do open up the
podcast app apple
uh the itunes app or open up uh spotify
on spotify you click follow on the apple
podcast app you're going to click
subscribe
we are climbing the charts i think we're
number 12 in
maybe business or investing category and
we're breaking into that top 10 and
we're not leaving when we get there so
how do we do that subscribe if you've
enjoyed this podcast you get value out
of it
just hit the button that's all you got
to do hit the button thank you
so shawn and i are both wearing harvard
shirts i actually planned this i saw you
a screenshot of you testing and i went
and grabbed my harvard shirt
i was about to go on this big like what
a coincidence this is amazing
no i i do have one that i wear um
but i saw you were wearing it so i
wanted to uh i wanted to wear the same
thing because we normally wear
black t-shirts yeah and you know for the
record neither of us went to harvard
uh but we both do this thing where we'll
wear harvard stuff and then people be
like oh
harvard and then you respond you're like
miss that campus love it love it
and you went on a tour and they actually
went to harvard yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're like oh you're wet like yeah
yeah yeah i got a groupon it was lovely
they showed me around oh four oh yeah
we almost overlapped it's like i don't
know i was just there for lunch but uh
yeah
oh like were you there at noon
con's even better ferguson didn't even
finish college so forgot his
of all of us he's the most he's the
smartest most successful one and he was
smart enough to drop out
after what freshman year sophomore year
uh i was there for a couple of years
uh i mean i tried to do i went to san
jose state i tried to do computer
engineering because obviously
that would have made sense but i was
running a company at the time
and every time i was deciding between
electrical physics or
on the phone with somebody trying to
make a deal and you know
you know which one won so yeah do you
want to give a background sean of fur
khan because
uh last time he was on we were way
smaller yeah
uh fur khan is one of my best buddies he
was the guy i started my last company
with or was co-founder cto
so you know most co-founder pairings i
would say the most common one
is one guy who can build and one guy who
can sell and that's kind of what we were
like i'm more like the sales guy and
he's more the building guy
and uh so yeah we worked together ahead
of six seven years sold the company
uh a year and a half ago for kind of
braved it out and made it one full year
at a big
corporation so i gotta give him props
for that that's like a you know
an endurance challenge for you um but
now
now he's now he's doing his own thing so
he's got f.inc
which is how do you describe it uh it's
uh i just want to build cool things with
cool people so that's what i'm focused
on
that's really it i would describe it as
you know if you're trying to start
something you want like a third
co-founder
it's an interesting emerging tech idea
uh that's where i get excited
and i want to put in time and money and
incubate these things with you
all right i'll give a different
description i'll give my my view of it
sweet basically uh fercon is investing
in himself
like 15 years ago whoever is that person
so if you're like a young engineer
and you want to make some [__] happen
and uh
man it'd be kind of helpful if you had
somebody who's been around the block
who's done it before
who can either give you money advice
build actually get in the code and build
with you
and so he's got this disc it's kind of
like y combinators you've got this
discord group
and every single company is like i don't
know like a 23 year old engineer
they get their own channel and then
basically on some of them furcon's
actually like
the back end engineer with them on some
of them he's like
the tough love investor who's like dude
why aren't you focused on growth why are
you talking about
all this other [__] and in some
cases it's like
uh oh you need to move to san francisco
and like live on my couch i think you've
done that with a few engineers of like
literally come here sleep on my couch
and i'll like
not just seed fund you i'll like [__]
babysit you and incubate you literally
and physically in my apartment
i want to spend some time actually
discussing that because i want
i want to like reminisce a little bit
but but first
by the way we got to congratulate furcon
also his he
since he's come on his last company uh
applovin ipo'd
um i don't know what what is it at now
ipod close to 30 billion dollars so
you know yeah i was gonna say we have to
give that part of the story which is
fur khan co-founded the company that is
currently publicly traded for 20 billion
dollars
yeah rich is what i'm trying to say so
that's like pretty important although it
looks like you guys did you guys just do
an earning so something happened today
where your stock just plummeted well not
plummeted but it went down
uh a fair bit uh yeah i don't know i
mean
all tech stocks are getting ravaged
right now um yeah
but you know yeah so congratulations
like basically that company
you guys are supposed to sell it for
also like a huge amount like three
billion or something like a couple years
ago
in it and it failed and then it turned
out to be a blessing in disguise it
seems well you should
you should explain that that's a good
story so we're working together and fur
crown's like dude
like i got some good news and he's like
you know my last company we're going to
sell for we're going to sell
uh they're going to sell it and i think
it's i don't know what it was 1.4
billion or something like that right
that's what the original sale price was
yeah i think they put a 1.4 billion
value
i think the terms were something like
they're going to put in a billion
dollars and the value would be at 1.4
they're going to buy a majority of the
company
uh most of the early employees would
have gotten liquidated unless you're
working there you would have gotten kind
of whatever
new grants right which would have been
an amazing outcome anyways right oh wow
you built a company 1.4 billion
that's you know that's a win that's a
grand slam but then
something happened what happened and how
did that work out in your favor
yeah so the company was an international
company it's a chinese company
and 2016 the elections happened and you
know
politics kind of changed a little bit
and i think in that process like it
started
looking like man this is like not gonna
go through like they're not gonna be
able to
get approval in the u.s for a foreign
entity to kind of buy this thing
and uh so that happened and then there's
some time
you know in every contract when a sale
happens there's like all these triggers
right like hey
you gotta complete by so and so date if
it doesn't happen then you know
whatever the contract might end and i
think in that time i mean i wasn't at
apple and i was working with you but
you know every time i talk to somebody
there they were like dude we're still
crushing it we're growing and it's still
kind of scaling up and so it looked like
the deal was not going to happen
the company had like multiplied in value
during that time and so now there's like
all this leverage on the company side to
be like well
we don't actually need this sale right
like we're a lot bigger than what that
value was and
i think they turned it into an
investment instead
with like non-voting or you know some
some kind of distinction there and we
ended up getting some liquidity then
which
was fantastic it was like over a billion
dollars like
felt great i felt like that was the exit
uh felt like that changed you know kind
of
what i could do in my life in terms of
where i spend my time um
but then they just kept growing the
company kept building and
they continued down the path they
partnered with kkr
and you know brought on i think harold
is on you know kind of the executive
team now and he's a
seasoned vet in the industry and they
just continue just to kind of you know
skyrocket and uh i don't know
to dumb it down app loving is basically
uh like
they you guys helped invent
advertisements that you see
in the middle of iphone games correct
yeah so we started as an ad tech
platform that's when i was there
and uh you know then after that they
brought up
you know kind of a the gaming side so
they have a gaming studio which
generates a lot of revenue
uh if you think of them as like almost
like a first party game
creator now that's where i think the
company's gone
they bought machine zone right so they
acquired a bunch of studios
they have their own studio so they're
almost more a gaming company than a
mobile ad network now so that's kind of
crazy but the funny part is
i remember you telling me like oh you
know we kind of did this sale
then a piece of paper is going to go sit
on someone's desk trump comes into
office and now
you know i think was a chinese company a
chinese company's buying this anything
that's over a billion dollars i believe
there's some rule that it has to get
like
you know a certain type of approval for
the transaction to go through
and then it just sat there for like i
don't know how many months six months
nine months something like that
and then when they came out of that he's
like yeah by the way like we kind of get
the best of both worlds
they made you know their buyout turned
into a minority investment so we still
got the money
but we get this free roll of great how
big can we build this and then
fast forward a few years and it goes
public uh at like we just kind of 20
times the value you know
we just kind of skipped over something
pretty amazing which is he
kind of was casual about it you guys
both were basically you built this ad
network that was doing wonderfully huge
company
and like i i i'm gonna say it in
the same way but basically you saw which
games are doing cool
and you go we're just gonna make games
kind of like that and make them popular
because we already know what's popular
before even the people making the games
know what's popular
and now you make all your revenue from
making games that's pretty astounding
right
yeah i mean um i saw all of this from
the outside but like there are some key
players in the company that i think were
really instrumental in this there was
this guy rafi
he like when when i you know when we
kind of created apple
and we were working on the products
before applovin uh this guy was just
like somebody adam knew he knew his
brother he had worked with them before
he was like this 19 year old guy he's
not going to go to college he's
you know all he wants to do is like do
something big and play video games so
like he'd spend
all day all night playing street fighter
but then he would talk to every single
kind of japanese mobile gaming company
all night and he would just grind and it
was
an awesome environment i mean i'm kind
of like the person where like if i get
really excited about something that's
all i want to do
that's what i was doing at the time so
i'm at the office rafi's at the office
you know we spend all night i'm hearing
his conversations i get pumped up about
it
and then kind of during the day we're
building all these things and you just
saw people
everywhere in the company that wanted to
do something big and went and got it so
raphael i think at some point in this ad
network was like i want to build games
they had built this thing called lion
studios within applovin i don't think it
was very big at the start like it was
kind of like
some small games but narafiya i think he
probably gets a lot of the credit to
like kind of spearheading that
and like just wanting to do it and you
know when i looked at the s1 and kind of
like dug into it it's like
i think it's like half the business now
you know there's obviously details on
how you determine
where the business is but i think it's
like half the company which is
incredible right like
started with this ad network and then
you know in two to three years kind of
towards the end of this one public era
you now have kind of built up the second
part of the business is also math
and you and the guy who started applovin
i mean it was a few of you guys but like
the main guy
his name is adam right yeah adam and
basically he had like a
i don't know if it was mild or or very
successful outcome at another thing
and didn't you say that he put in like
four million dollars of his own money
which i don't know if that was a lot or
a little to him but uh a pretty
substantial amount of his own money
and you guys kind of like [__] around
for like two years
like point like you would say that like
well let's try this and it didn't work
and you're like let's just go play video
games and think about it
like like wasn't there like something
like that we're like oh we'll figure it
out
yeah i mean adam john and andrew were
like the three co-founders that like
they had worked together before
they had some done a couple of other
companies that did well i mean john is
like
nobody knows john but john is like he
worked on the first ad server on the
internet
i believe that got picked up by
doubleclick and you know kind of that
went on to
google and then he worked at like vmware
he had done all these different roles
he's like technical but then
very marketing focus very product
focused and uh
you know so it's like he was just an
interesting person to have in the mix
and then adam is like
he had already kind of you know he
started i think in equities trading in
the chicago stock exchange and then
gotten into you know ads and marketing
and then they had built a company i
believe it was called
ah and i can't remember they said game
fly or you know some something like that
and it was like
probably a really good outcome but then
not where you know it wasn't like a
massive outcome where he's like oh i can
retire forever and i can
you know like this is all i want to do
and i've kind of made it
and in the first couple conversations
with him i remember walking down
university avenue with him and he was
just like you know i want to make
something so big that i can walk down
this street
and people would know me and it's like
university avenue in palo alto
for people to know you must have done
something like really big right it's
like
every who's who in tech walks down there
and i was like okay okay i want to kind
of like take a really big shot but
the m3 put in the initial funding i
think it was like around four or five
million bucks if i remember correctly
but
it was a lot in the sense that it gave
us many years of runway
to work on whatever we started with one
project called style page
we did that for like nine months that
was kind of like pinterest we really
quickly realized we're like
you know five dudes in like palo alto
with no fashion sense trying to build
a fashion website this is not going to
work very well yeah like
you know just wranglerjeans.com it's
that easy that's your website where
you're going to stop you know
you don't need a pinterest board to find
lee jeans yeah exactly
and uh and then we messed around with a
lot of different ideas and some of them
weren't very good
and i think sean we dealt with this a
lot right like you get excited about
something because you have to come up
with an idea
you make it you're not really that
confident with it before you even launch
you're like this is trash i don't i
don't even want this anymore to get it
away from me
so there was definitely some of that
yeah but
you you i think one of the things worth
mentioning is that you
which i think it's worth mentioning
because i remember
every time i built a company i'm always
like well this is just how i'm doing it
it's probably real wrong but like
i don't know the smart people probably
do it this other way and i remember you
talk i remember feeling very comforted
when you told me like
yeah that love when we went through nine
ideas you know is it this is it that is
it this is that and like you know some
false hopes of like uh kind of works uh
no it's not gonna work out
and then in between you're like yeah
there were some days we just came to the
office we didn't have the idea to work
on and so we just played fifa for a
bunch of hours and we would go
eat talk come back play some more fifa
then we would go home like there were
days
like weeks like that and i remember
thinking all right that's probably not
the like the method you should choose
but like
it reminded me that like success is not
so
glamorous like you know they show in the
movies where it's like oh i have the
idea i'm a visionary
i got it right away from day one and
then we work hard and we just
a b c d e it's done you know and so uh i
don't know is that a fair
representation of what you what you
experience yeah it's definitely
non-linear
i mean you can work really really hard
for a long time and feel like you've
made zero progress
and you could be doing all the right
stuff you could be making the right
calls and
the other challenges you don't know like
you don't get feedback right away on the
things you're doing or are good i mean
you get customer feedback but you don't
get this kind of meta feedback that like
the general type of things i'm working
on are going to kind of work and hit
and uh i mean style page was kind of one
idea that we really dug ourselves into
that everything between style page and
then app love in the ad network
was just like you know
it's just like kind of really small
projects that you're not super confident
about you're trying to find some edge
you're trying to learn something
and you know mobile was just getting big
android was getting big there's
some opportunities there but you just
don't know you know it's like how vr is
today you're like
i believe this is going to be a lot
bigger in the future
what is exactly what people are going to
do it's really hard to predict and when
you tell somebody
they usually go nobody's going to do
that well if nobody can predict these
behaviors how do we build them
you have to have this kind of like blind
conviction towards something
and also like get that right so it's
like yeah it's really hard
yeah you definitely need some luck you
got to pick the right thing this guy
adam
how do you sell how do you say adam's
last name furugi
so farooqi adam ferugi he's the ceo now
and from what i've read about him i
don't know him he seems like a wonderful
ceo like the glass door reviews are
great he wins all these awards he seems
like a lovely guy i've seen interviews
with him
and then but what you're describing is
like a bunch of really like relaxed
calm people just like i'm kind of
dismissing it but not really like you
guys are just kind of messing around and
like
uh trying to help yeah which isn't of
course that's not the reality but
how did this guy go from being
this like kind of relaxed calm dude just
trying to
hang out and find a hit to leading a 20
billion
publicly traded company i mean when i
look at him he looks pretty polished he
looks like
a good good guy that's like a pretty
amazing transformation
yeah and so i i think relax is probably
the wrong
the wrong word i mean we were intense
when we played fifa it was like i'm
gonna beat you eight times in a row it
wasn't a
casual game of fisa fifa so everything
was competitive
and we would play mobile games
competitively that was a lot of our
interest
app oven when we started was actually an
app where you could see
what games and apps other people were
playing in your social network it was
like
kind of like a feat of act that was a
first iteration of app loving
and it was because we just wanted to see
what people were playing because we
wanted to kind of get those games and be
competitive within it so
he's always been competitive i think you
really uh see that in him and
but you know i used to say like like fur
crown's work schedule
is like roll into the office at 11
lunch with the crew catch up on what
people are up to
just starts getting humming around you
know does a couple meetings starts
getting hung around three four
and then basically like by like 8 p.m
to 3 a.m is when ferkan does his work
and then he repeats it the next day
and so for i remember in our company
there was a bunch of people who were
just you know
regular human beings that would work in
a nine to five and then they would go
turn off their brain and go home
and like for some of them it was really
hard to have a boss and kind of like a
leader
who's on a completely alternate schedule
some people were totally fine with it
they made it work and then we recruited
a bunch of like raffy type dudes who
were like
oh cool we stayed up until 3am here like
great that's my optimal schedule too
like
i'm down with that and so but at app 11
you had told me that adam was the
opposite he was
coming at nine leave at four or five
whatever he's got like five kids i think
and like every minute was efficient
whereas i gotta say like
the way you work it's not that every
minute is like boom boom boom i'm doing
this
this this like even at our company we
would take video game breaks every day
at 4 pm and go play super smash bros for
an hour right like
you had very opposite styles but you
guys made it work
yeah i think adam is like make every
minute count
and you see that uh and how he like
operates and that's why he's the ceo of
a 20 billion dollar company is because
everything happens very fast very
efficiently uh
like when a decision is made the whole
company knows about it when
movement's happening it's immediate it's
like make decisions fast
be strong with your kind of movements
you know outside of it follow through
with it quickly
like those are qualities i think are
really really critical in a ceo
i mean for me it's like i want to make
obviously every day count like i work a
lot
when i'm excited about something and the
apple open times was that when
something's growing i take it seriously
but you know i know that creative work
is like it happens in kind of these
moments of flow if you get two or three
good flow states a week
i feel like you produce a lot and i
think most developers or creative people
or builders don't feel this like
not every hour is super efficient but
there's there's some times where
maybe it's because you did all this
stuff to build up to it or you got the
right conditions but
you hit like three or four of those a
week man you're you're really you know
humming you're producing a lot and a lot
of impacts happening and so
i always focus on impact and you know i
think it was a good pairing because
i would just work super hard to go and
tackle the next like
technology barrier with my team and then
the next morning adam would just drive a
bunch of traffic by the time i rolled in
at noon it was like
we knew the test worked or not and you
know that was like awesome just to feel
the first time i've ever felt somebody
like take control of growth and like
literally say actually we're gonna get
this answer today
and obviously if you have like you know
a good bank account and you can kind of
fund it
you can spend money to make your answers
happen faster we got a lot of cycles in
in those you know times we were building
these crap apps we didn't waste like a
year building some garbage app because
very quickly we knew it wasn't gonna
work and why and we tried all the
variants of it and we got
we had like confidence that we were done
with that idea like oh we tried it it's
not gonna work
we're not gonna be lingering about this
you know so let's switch to ideas so me
and you do a call every week
um it's one hour and it's called the
cool [__] hour and every time i do it
i'm like damn i wish i'd recorded that
for myself
but also people would love this and so i
i want to do that basically
you guys do this every week yeah we've
sometimes missed some weeks but you know
i had a kid and stuff like that but
we've been doing it
uh pretty regularly for a couple ever
since he left uh you know twitch i was
like well i still want to
hang out and keep in touch that's like
the best part of when we used to work
together was just shooting the [__]
about
stuff that's cool and because fergan in
his own words he told me this once was
like
i'm kind of in the first 10 000 people
to try any new technology and like
really dive deep and understand it
because he does that he just sees a
bunch of cool [__] before
the mainstream does and so my hack is
well i'm never going to be as smart as
this guy i'm never going to understand
technology i'm not going to learn how to
code
but i can be friends with him and he
could like explain it to me like i'm a
kindergartner like
uh i'm really into this right now check
this out watch watch this demo here
try this out here open up this website
watch this and so we do that and the the
thing with
most of my relationships including this
podcast i'm talking at least 50 plus
percent of the time
because i'm a talker when i do the cool
[__] out with a fur god i'm like
i just sit back into my desk and i like
take notes as like oh this is cool
and i only stopped to ask clarifying
questions of like wait how does that
work
so i want to jump into some of those
things so
we'll keep it open-ended i have a few
that i know you're interested in i can
guide us there but let's start with
open-ended which is
what are some things that are just cool
or interesting to you it doesn't have to
be like
something you're working on necessarily
but where is furcon's attention right
now what stuff has caught your eye
yeah i would say um there's probably
three
major things one is uh in the hardware
space there's just
there's just this trend that i feel like
i can't get out of my mind which is
you know commodity hardware whether it's
like a raspberry pi kind of a simple
device like that or off-the-shelf gears
and things like that
plus software like machine learning
equals very advanced piece of hardware
same raspberry pi yeah well i i don't
know what the application is but it's
basically like a fifty dollar
i don't i don't remember how much it
costs now yeah it's like a thirty
computer it's like a little board
and it's important because now in a
developer
previously they would have had to design
their own little small computer board
to go build a small like you know if you
wanted to build a roomba you'd have to
go design a little computer to put in
the roomba
then design the roomba now you can kind
of go pick up this like
computer that's just a little board and
you can put it into anything
like you know it took half your company
away of what you needed to do to make
this happen
who makes raspberry uh it's a company
called adafruit i believe
um but they're they're like an
independent company they're like
probably one of the biggest obvious
maker space companies around
um because they've you know i think
they've sold like i want to say like 100
million of these devices now
and so they're just crushing it they're
just as well so
what's what's an example of something
that you or somebody has built with a
raspberry pi
just so people have a tangible example
so like uh there's another device of
this
from nvidia i'm using the nvidia jetson
it's like a little version of a gpu but
i basically have a little gpu plugged
into my tv
it has a webcam on it and you know we
messed around with some like pose
estimation so like
you know you can open my tv and you can
basically stand there and a little ball
will come and if you hit that ball
like it'll go blue or you made like a
connect like an xbox kinect you just
made like a bootleg version of it
and then we kind of did some hand
gestures where if you you know we
basically i think that this
this and then this that's kind of like
the three gestures and we can kind of
read that on the other side and so and
he basically just put up
like you put up like a one or two or
three basically right yeah and this was
for me like you know i like to go
and mess around with it my idea if i
wanted to do this as an idea i would do
like
uh the best fitness product would be you
buy this little device it plugs into
your tv because everybody has a tv on
their wall
now your tv is this awesome fitness game
uh and you could just do like everything
i think i wanted to call it like fit cam
or
you know something like that but uh
instead of like that company that sold
to lululemon for like 500 600 million
yeah exactly two thousand dollars right
here
for thousands of dollars that you have
to mount onto your wall well you already
have a screen on your wall called your
tv what if you could just turn it into
something smart
that's one of the like for thirty
dollars instead of three thousand
dollars
dude i have uh i have like a mere
competitor called tempo i pay 50 bucks a
month for the programming and then two
grand for the machine
oh yeah and it's basically a flat screen
tv with uh
they don't call it a camera because they
don't want to freak people out because
like
you work out like i work out shirtless
in my underwear basically so they don't
call it a camera but they call it a
sensor and it could like tell you if
your are your poses in good
form or not good form and uh it counts
your pose it counts your reps so you can
compete
pretty cool yeah and so that's one i'm
going to tell you about this other
company i invested in them but i i just
really really excited about it so i'm
going to tell you guys
this company called neurosci they make a
brain computer interface so this sounds
like
future but it's now it's basically a
device and i actually wish i had it next
to me but
you just put it on your head you can go
ahead if you want i want i want to see
if
it's within the room it's not going in
the room
you know how you know how on talk shows
like uh morning shows they have a guest
come in and they're like here's the
latest products that you can buy for
your kids this holiday season
and they're at a table and they go this
product is this is this and they set it
down they go to the next one
that's what fur con is right now
basically it's that segment where
someone is just like has placed like
eight cool things on the table
and they're just going from thing to
thing to thing just dropping bombs and
i'm like oh great
cool got it next you know what i mean
that's what's going on right this is uh
fvc this is fur khan's qvc competitor
where he just picks up objects and like
this is a fantastic holiday gift for the
family
yeah and so this is for you know kind of
like developers and whatnot still but
this is what the device looks like and
i'll kind of give you guys a closer look
but you can see these little
uh probe looking things so this would
basically kind of rest on your head like
that
and what this does is it listens to eeg
waves
happening in your brain and i think
there's many different wavelengths but
you know these guys have identified some
set of them and so
why why does this kind of relate to the
story we're talking about there's a
little computer that's inside here that
you know like wouldn't have been able to
happen 10 years ago
and so because you could put a little
computer here that has wi-fi on it
that can take these signals in and
transmit it to the internet
this device is viable now and you can so
so you you wear that
and it helps measure your like what
focus or your kind of are you in flow
state
it's kind of like a fitbit in some way
for your brain or what
so the device itself first takes in raw
signals so it can detect
a lot of stuff they've added some
machine learning right so the second
part they added software
and they pre-programmed all these
different actions so there's some stuff
like
are you focused right now are you calm
right now
uh kind of things like that are you
gonna enter a sleeping state
they can detect all of these conditions
but there's other things
that i'm really excited about uh where
it can detect
uh if you think about like pinching your
left hand like if you think about doing
this actually but don't do it
it can pick up that signal or if you
think about moving your hand
your right arm it could pick up that
signal specifically and so
you know you could think of this as both
a receive state and detect things
but also as an interface to kind of you
know
without having to move a muscle just
thinking about a muscle
change change the channel without going
and picking up the remote so
the guy who made this is like 17 right
for 18. um
i i don't know his age i think he's a
little bit older than that but yeah
you know there's this guy alex i believe
he has a neuroscience background and the
ceo is this guy aj
um and you know what's funny is i bought
this device
as a person right like i'm just like i
bought this device i think i was
probably in the first 100 or 200 to buy
it
um and then i was like i sent them a
message i'm like i love this i'm like an
investor
like can i talk to you guys and i don't
think they responded to me and then
um then i joined they had they sent a
message like hey do you want to schedule
like uh
like customer call like they were doing
customer discovery now my sweet
so i like joined this customer discovery
called do the whole thing
but then at the end i'm like dude i
really love this like this is me there's
a bunch of stuff about me
not some rando but like i'm like really
excited about this like i want to invest
like
and then he was like still kind of like
okay like
kind of like aggressive in the customer
call to kind of get this but then we
followed up after i talked to him and
ended up investing a little bit of money
into them but i love these devices i
love these things where it's like
small piece of commodity hardware plus
advanced machine learning equals
potentially massive new output right
like you know and i can go into some
random ideas on how i would use this but
also
this is called we got to make sure we
let everyone know it's called
neurocity so their website is
neurocity.com
their website is so awesome when i'm on
this
it okay so it's basically what this kind
of looks like it basically looks like a
set of headphones but you don't put it
on your ear you put it
up on your head a little bit it costs i
think 900
and they claim that they manage your
focus with music
and then you minimize distractions and
shifts your focus and hacks your flow
this is a
brilliant website i almost would buy
this just because like
it looks so mysterious is the right one
maybe
i mean it's definitely something new and
early and you know when people say like
hey we're gonna manage
your flow state you always you know what
do we all do we kind of call [__] on
it right you're like wait like
are you gonna do that how are you gonna
hack my body right and so
uh you get a lot of snake oil in the
world there but this device uh it can
for sure detect when i'm focused
it can detect when i'm calm and
different uh points
and i've programmed it to basically like
when i have it connected to my computer
i can move
my desktop around or you know i
basically wanted to like see can i open
brave
from right like and open an application
by thinking about something and i can do
that
that's miraculous to me like that's
things you like read about
in a book somewhere and then it was in
the jetsons maybe but it doesn't it
didn't really exist
can you really do that so you can think
to yourself like move the cursor and it
works
do you think move it do you think open
chrome what do you actually think of to
get it to happen
yeah so basically uh i programmed it to
these kind of thinking of motor
functions so they have these
pre-programmed like 40 or 80 motor
functions
like push pull move your right arm move
your left arm move your index finger
like
and you don't move it you just think
about that and then you do a little
training step
so like it just tells you think about
moving your index finger
and then stop thinking about it and so
it does like a little machine learning
loop like
20 iterations or whatever and then you
know again this is a developer device
still but
i can get it to run some arbitrary code
when i
think about my index exactly dude i'm so
excited to give this to my dog or to
like an eight
dog go to sleep well we used to make fun
of craig clements came on here and he's
like
best idea he had three ideas at the end
and his best idea was dog vr and we were
like that's the stupidest idea
but this is actually better uh because
this would be like a way to communicate
with a dog
uh if you could get the dog to train it
but i don't know that seems a little
difficult um all right freaking so that
was the first one which is
cheap commodity hardware that now lets a
software programmer like
make hardware without having to have a
lab and
you know physical material engineering
making motherboards and do all that
stuff all right that's one
one trend what are some others so the
second trend i mean we're all into this
but
obviously the d5 crypto world there's
just a lot of fun activity happening
there
and i've just you know it's one of those
things where you just see it happening
and you want to be a part of it and you
read about it and you're
building stuff but you know i was
working with you and then i was working
at twitch i hadn't really built anything
in this space and so
you know just recently i would say the
last six months i've just been writing
you know solidity code trying to think
about what kind of applications to build
what's interesting and my entire view of
everything is
there's these massive hype cycles then
these hype cycles go away which
is obviously what happens right when
kind of this massive hype happens
then there's a stopping point there
where the real building begins and the
real value would be created
and all of these kind of industries flow
like that vr crypto
uh these kind of hardware spaces machine
learning back in the day and so
that's where we are in the decentralized
and crypto world right now
and all i want to do is build very
valuable legitimate products that serve
a real purpose
and kind of go from there and you know
so let's talk about crypto real quick so
you
uh you can apologize now for not
including me in the ether crowd sale
which i know you were
on top of at the time did you buy in the
actual crowdsource right after
i bought a little bit after the crowd
sale but it was like single-digit
dollars
it was very cheap i'm i'm pretty sure i
said it out loud at lunch ever you know
you did
i remember you saying that and i was
like i remember thinking ethereum
dumb name uh like that's that's like a
weird name normal people aren't going to
want to
own ethereum like that seems weird
literally that was my
my my dumb ass thinking and then like
every you know year since then i sort of
think about why don't i just listen to
more deferracon why don't i just do the
things he says to stop thinking for
myself a little bit
so so that's kind of where i'm at so you
you initially bought
some crypto i remember sitting next to
you while you were buying you know
random ass you know
good good stuff and then the [__] coins
also just [__] around seeing what's
what
and then you sort of showed me what's
going on at d5 so if people don't know
here's how i'll explain d5 and then you
tell me what you would say so
today there's like the normal financial
system there's a stock market
there's banks you can go drive and park
and walk into when you walk into that
bank you can say hey
uh here's my money store it safely for
me like put it in a savings account give
me some interest maybe
um or i'd like to take a loan out and
then they say great let's just decide if
you
are credit worthy if you can get a loan
and how much you can get so that's the
traditional financial system like in a
nutshell the
simplified version there's a parallel
like you know a parallel universe
where all those same things have been
built through
code now instead of by law right so we
used to
write down you know contracts and put
them in you know lawyers would write the
contracts and now programmers write the
contracts and so you could do all those
same things so
you've showed me tools and had me got me
set up where
you take your crypto money and you can
put it in a savings account and you can
earn five percent 10 a year
of yield so you earn much better
interest rates you can lend it to other
people or you can take loans and get
loans for things
um so explain kind of like maybe what
part is most interesting to you or give
an example of something you've done with
crypto where
you're actually not just like
speculating in the in the defy space but
you're actually
using this alternate financial system
and so
what's an example what what you were
just saying what's like your favorite
platform for that
so furcon showed me a couple that i like
so um you know so one
is compound right so it's compound dot
finance is a website you go to
and what it says is hey great you have
ether you don't want to sell your ether
but so i did a very simple loan
um i went to compound finance i
staked or basically like i put up ether
that i own
i said great here's let's say 100 ether
and
then it says great you can you can just
lend that out to other people who want
to borrow ether and
you can earn this percent annually and
you know if you go to if i go to wells
fargo
i'm going to go get 0.001 you know a
year
on my savings account whereas with this
it was like you can get seven percent a
year or five percent a year it's like
you know
actually like a decent saving a decent
interest rate
or i could say great i put my 100 ether
up and i'd like to borrow
some of this other coin so what i did
just as a test of the system i said
can i get a loan off my cryptocurrency
so i put up ether
to borrow usdc which is a
a stable coin made by coinbase which
basically is supposed to be one usdc is
supposed to always be one dollar
so i got usdc and then i went to
coinbase and i sold my usdc and i got
dollars and i said wow
i i just put up i just like basically
showed that i have this ether and i
locked up ether into this account
for temporarily as long as i want and i
got a
us dollar loan that i could go use to go
buy you know
a pizza right now if i want to and i was
like well that's pretty sweet i never
had to talk to a banker fill out an
application
do a credit check i didn't have to do
anything and i was able to get a loan
and now what a lot of people do is they
do that they put ether up they get a
loan of
some stable coin they use a stable going
to buy more ether or to go buy some
other
coin and kind of gamble like kind of
like leveraged gambling
so there's other things you can do but i
just did a really simple one with
where furcon was showing yeah and uh i
think uh lending is a big part of it
i mean lending is dangerous in many ways
like you know i look at lending as like
this is bad that's my first reaction to
any lending thing because people do that
right they basically
um take it and they leverage if you take
it and you have purpose behind it and
you're a long-term holder of something
that makes a lot of sense right like
you can kind of do that and and the
reason i find defy exciting is
you could take all the rules that you've
seen get destroyed in like you know the
2008 crash or
the dot-com crash and you could put a
contract where
that can't happen and so for example
there's this protocol called liquidity
protocol it's a new protocol
they do zero percent interest loans on
your ease
so you can put up ease you take a zero
percent loan
and what they've done is they've created
this system where they have a stability
pool
that will liquidate people if they go
below their collaterization ratio
and so what happens with banks explain
that in simple terms so
okay so how do i how do i get um how do
because they're not doing a credit check
because they're not asking for my w-2
income
how do they make sure that this loan
eventually gets paid back how do they do
that
so you put in let's say 100 ethereum
right so you put in some amount
that has a dollar value today and they
let you take out
their token called l usd it's like a usd
stablecoin
uh so now you have the stable coin you
can trade it for other stable coins or
other coins or
take it to coinbase you know using
whatever mechanism
and kind of get it to dollars uh what
you've done is you've put up your
ethereum
and you have to basically maintain some
what they call collateralization ratio
like you have to be over
the lending amount by at least 10
percent otherwise you're going to get
liquid
and the action of liquidating means
somebody will go and take your ethereum
and buy it for
a discount because they have to do this
liquidation task
and you know that's the risk you're
putting this collateral up like you
would
in in another case now so it's like if
you know i take a mortgage out i can't
make my mortgage payments because i lost
my job
well the bank has my house as collateral
they can foreclose on my house it's
the same concept but instead of a
physical house it's whatever collateral
you put up initially to get the loan
your stake
and so the danger is i put up ethereum
the price of ethereum is very volatile
it goes down a lot i was aggressive with
my ratio
and i kind of went below this number and
i got liquidated i still have my loan
amount
right so but there's obviously risks
with these platforms like there would be
a risk of
buying a you know investment property
and not being able to make rent on it or
not be able to make mortgage what i like
about it is the underneath where
um in 2008 the bankers just went to the
government and whoever else and was like
we need new rules right now we're dying
and so
you kind of invent new rules this rule
is built into the protocol
if you're at below this ratio some
liquidator can come in and
and be the liquidator you can't you
don't get a choice
of hey is this going to happen or not
it's encoded and so
when you build you know financial
products with you know directly encoded
values
it makes it so that it's going to happen
whether it's a good situation for you or
not
whether they like you know how you
presented yourself or not like
you know and and having gone through
you know bad times as a founder and gone
through bad credit like
i don't have good credit today still
it's like i have a lot of money in the
bank
and sometimes i can't go get a credit
card because like literally my credit
still sucks from like
whatever seven years ago or five years
ago however long ago
those problems were um and if one little
things happen
like i had a small credit card that i
forgot about it's literally a 300
thing i missed some like yearly you know
payment fee because you know every year
you got that fee
man it showed up on my credit oh that's
a huge ding doesn't matter who you
really are what you can do
if that financial system sucks if you
have the ability to kind of um
do some of these actions i believe you
should be able to do them and that's the
most interesting thing about d5 is so
that's
permissionless so that's the general
like that's a good i think general
overview because
most people don't really understand what
what what is even the point of this how
does this work
uh let's go specific are you doing
anything cool with d5 do you have any
good trades going are you making money
doing this are you
are you actually doing anything in the
device space right now
i think uh uniswop is probably one of my
favorite companies in the space
and i think we've talked about this a
little bit but what unit swap did and
i'll give you kind of the simple version
of it is
usually when you wanted to trade two
assets you had to create a marketplace
so let's say
i have one sean coyne and i want to sell
it i need sam to show up
and buy that sean coin right and if
there aren't two sides and they don't
agree on the price this trade won't
happen
and what uniswap did and i think there
were some others before it but uniswap
has become the biggest player in this
space
is they created a one-sided trading
market where
you know a buyer or seller can show up
and they're trading against what's
called a liquidity pool
the investors come in and put in both
sides of the trade marketplace so like
one ethereum and three thousand dollars
would create like let's say a liquidity
pool
then sean you can just show up and say i
want to sell and you're going to sell
against
this pool uh you don't need another side
the pool is always the other side
and they've created a simple algorithm
they call it like you know an amm and
automated market maker
where you know they want to keep the
price close and depending on how much
liquidity there is and
how much you're willing to sell it's
going to slip away from that amount and
that's where the price movements will
happen and you were
in those pools you were saying i'm
making good money by being the liquidity
pool
give us a sec what what was the yield
you could get let's say you put a
thousand dollars in what were you making
being the liquidity provider
so uh obviously in the earlier days of
unit swap the pool yields were very high
like you could see 100
plus on like fairly good assets and and
it's really important to think about you
have two sides of this market right so
if you have if you're in the ethereum
and us dollar pool
when ethereum is going up you're like
losing some of it
right because you're giving it away uh
to kind of to kind of like receive
basically dollars
and you know so if you want to hold a
lot of ethereum long run
it doesn't really make sense to be in
some of these pools that are unaligned
so i always try to find things that are
connected together so like
two stable coin pools a usdc and dipole
that does you know anywhere from like
eight to fifteen percent and that's been
like that
on the low end of the spectrum for the
last year plus i mean i'm holding
effectively what you know we'll call it
dollars on both sides of the puzzle
and people need to trade between these
assets and i'm willing to be the trade
partner for them along with a lot of
other people
and you basically get a little bit of a
fee and that's where the liquidity pool
makes money
so holding you know dollar on this side
or a dollar on this side
feels good if there's something very
well aligned with ethereum so
if you believe ethereum and bitcoin will
kind of
together flow upwards that could be a
very good pool for you to kind of take
what they call rap bitcoin and ethereum
and be in that pool
and uniswap made all this happen from
the consumer side to make a one-sided
trade
but also as an investor to come into a
liquidity pool and say hey i'm willing
to kind of put up both of these assets
and then i want to make some fees as
people do this right okay so all right
so that's
that's good i think a little probably a
little too complicated for the
general audience at this point so i'm
wearing a harvard shirt
that's about it oh sorry my
sean i told you about this book i read
about vertical farming and uh
you know basically like i read that wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
you guys just were talking about crypto
stuff and then he just said
i've got something i think sam will like
farming
this was one of our cool [__] hours was
he's like i came in thinking he's going
to tell me about
you know wbtc and i'm like oh [__] i got
to go look up all these acronyms he's
like no vertical farming
i was like oh brilliant tell me about it
right because furcon's got a wide range
some days i remember early on at when we
were working together he was like
when uber had just kind of was getting
big he's like i'm thinking he's like i
got a bunch of friends we're kind of
like you know
not doing a whole lot nowadays i'm
thinking about just renting like five by
five cars and just having them like run
a fleet like i think i could just make x
dollars
doing zero work by running my own little
taxi fleet on uber
or he was like uh you know there's these
i forgot what it was float spas or cryo
tank yeah company what was that one that
you were really into
yeah uh you know the cryotanks are
something that you know if you have bad
joints like me
it's like a you know night and day
difference on how your body feels
and so you know like i still want to put
one in
and i think in the lab that i'm spinning
up over here we'll get to that probably
at some point but
wait what's the what's this what's said
lab
i'm i'm building a hardware and robotics
lab here in san francisco as a part of
f dot inc and you know the idea is
software you can do in a coffee shop and
a living room
but you can't really build any one of
these even off-the-shelf hardware
products
in your living room and so what i want
to do is take a lot of founders who are
interested or future founders
we're interested in building these ideas
i'm going to have a machine shop and an
electronic shop and a robotic shop
in this facility gonna be in this iconic
location
and my goal is just to get like a bunch
of talented hungry people in this roof
and just have
a great energy and build together and so
you see these companies form out of
universities
because they have two things they have a
shop there that you can access mostly
for free
and then they have people in the shop
that turns into your community like
as a kid i can just show up and stand
next to you while you're doing something
and you go
you don't give me a weird look you go oh
you wanna you know how to use this no
okay let me show you
like that little bit might be the
difference between you
willing to try and kind of get into a
field or not and uh where are you
going to support that what was that
where
where in the city you said it's iconic
location can you see yeah
we're looking at a place at fort mason
in san francisco so it's not complete
yet
um but that's kind of like for me like
the iconic locations or i can see the
golden gate bridge i can be on the water
we've explored stuff on the piers in
general uh in chrissy field
fort mason like these locations when i
go there i get excited
you know like going to monkey inferno
was a fantastic office but
now outside it wasn't that great like
soma mission these areas i don't get
excited when i go there and
i usually do there too much how much are
you willing to invest in
to sink into this thing to make it
interesting it's gonna be a lot it'll
probably cost about half a million bucks
a year just to even like have the base
building in place and uh
you know my guess is it'll be double
that just from you know the people that
i want to bring in
and kind of investments i want to do and
what i want to support
uh i want to like i i actually ran a
plastic fabrication shop in a small
machine shop a long time ago
and so i've done a lot of this i've
welded and now i've worked on cars so
like
i actually have a lot of this interest
and uh i'm more excited to have my own
cnc
and my own machines and things to work
with as well so dude you're so cool
yeah so sam the reason i said you're
gonna like this
idea in companies because uh i don't
listen to very many podcasts but
i do listen to this podcast this is
probably the only one i listen to this
is not
maybe we're taking that testimonial to
the moon and i'm not even just pampering
you guys sean i mean you know me i'm not
going to tell you like it is but i
really do listen to you guys
i know because i'm pretty sure you
didn't listen at the beginning when i
was just interviewing folks and then now
that it's ideas it's shooting the [__]
sam's here he's listening now
yeah and uh so you talked about like hey
you know you just sold the company by
the way congratulations to you as well
and uh you were talking about how like
you want to get your hands kind of into
things and
yeah you want to like do some of that so
i was like oh okay if i ever get back on
the pod i'm gonna tell sam about this
idea
uh and so i'm by the way i'm sitting
here taking notes i'm just writing all
this down
and so i read this book and this book
was talking about vertical farming
i think i don't know i don't remember
the name of the book but basically
um you know the first couple of chapters
it really talks about what the major
problem in the us
is as you know as you're producing a lot
of food and the world right the world
went from
i think 3 billion people 100 years ago
to like almost 8 billion now like
it's a pretty massive difference in like
how many people are on the world you're
starting to see effects like
we see the wildfires here in california
you hear about all these things and so
what's happening is as you start farming
in soil you basically destroy the soil
and after some period of time
you get no yield out of the soil and so
about 10 years ago 15 years ago vertical
farming got very popular as a way to put
food production closer to cities like
new york city requires you know millions
of acres outside of new york city to
support it
wouldn't it make sense for that to be in
the city well how do you do that well
you could put it in these buildings you
could put it under kind of uv lights and
you could drive water through it through
hydroponics and this got really popular
a lot of people invested in it
uh so it's kind of like a particular
time it's for someone like me who's
zero zero nature knowledge what would
to make paint a mental picture what is a
vertical farm bro have you never grown
weed in your
in your apartment no i don't smoke weed
i never grew weed
i don't do drugs i don't do crimes i
don't i don't die there but i feel like
every 16 year old has at least grown one
pot plant at red high school
yeah so you know you know you think
about plants in the ground because they
need kind of nutrients from soil but
really they just need some of those
nutrients and you could just put them
as long as you deliver them to the roots
it's going to pull that in and so people
figured out hey you can grow stuff
without soil and that that's a huge
that's just a big unlock because
it doesn't have to go in the ground so
it's going to use water
right correct to use water and there's
been more advances now where
it's not just water but it's like you
know i think they call it aeroponics but
it's just misted right so it's kind of
like more yield against the root
and you know you still have to power it
with sunlight so you could put it inside
a warehouse but you need sunlight and so
big uv lights was kind of the strategy
and so phase one of vertical farming was
we're going to put them in high rises
we're going to take
some floors and we're going to turn them
into a farm floor and that should
support the building and
these are normally the pictures that you
see what people are kind of dreaming
about vertical farming it's a giant
building
where a bunch of them are farms and it
looks cool uh but in practice it was
like kind of a
warehouse like a data center and you
know that's where it ended up living and
i think that's fine the the reason these
guys i got excited about they're called
nebulum farms
and what they do is they basically have
uh direct to consumer
um lettuce micro greens and tomatoes
that's what they sell you and so you
know they started kind of in a different
phase like kind of like
hey we're building cool tech like we've
been in this sean before where you're
excited about
computer vision and doing this thing but
actually along the way they realized
well
we don't really want to license out our
thing we can't franchise this we can't
do like all these other ideas we had
people actually just want this and what
if we could put up a farm near you
and i think they have their first farm
in idaho and they just have a monthly
subscription to get lettuce and tomatoes
and
these things show up to your door and i
mean today they do same day harvest to
delivery
because they've kind of taken the
process down to this simple thing they
have this basic
form and you can see some of the
pictures that they have on their website
of what their farm looks like
uh but it looks like a little data
center it's like a rack of
lettuce there's a little light that will
kind of rotate and like
give it sunlight and on the top there's
a mister that kind of like you know make
sure it's
called what's this called nebulum farms
nebula b-u-l-l-a-m
farms and you know like if you ever
get a chance to go taste some vertical
farmed lettuce
you will notice the taste difference
like it is not the same lettuce
you're like wait lettuce has taste it is
good crispy like
it actually makes a huge difference in
the quality of product and
i believe they can make this happen you
know same-day harvest to delivery for a
large part of america
so what they're on their website it says
less water so you use 98 percent less
water and in places like california
where there's like
droughts water shortages that's a big
deal no pesticides because it's an
indoor sort of controlled environment
and no soils to know bugs right that's
why you don't need the pesticide
right uh it says less human handling i
don't know about that
uh so always fresh and basically the the
goal would be hey here's an eco-friendly
thing but also
this taste this produce it tastes better
and you've actually had it so
what's the no [__] like is it if i
didn't know blind taste test would i be
able to tell the difference between
these two or whatever yeah
and we should do this like you know
there's a couple of other brands that
have gotten popular that you can pick up
in stores i think there's one called
plenty
uh that shows up in stores um and i
think there's a lot of people that have
wanted to do this
but if the business isn't gonna work the
tech is not gonna hold it right like
that's the same thing as software like
this problem exists everywhere and so
if you're building some emerging tech
thing you can't keep talking about how
great the tech is
and so the direct to consumer angle it
resonated with me because it's like
okay i've seen grocery delivery i've
seen some of these things where you
could get like fruit in a bar
well if you can produce the fruit
yourself like you just have a machine
that can produce fruit that's the
vertical farm well why don't you become
the biggest farm
in america really quickly by kind of
going city to city and
doing that and you've seen uber
you know kind of build the biggest farm
in america now right
now the way that he was describing i'm
like all right they're mailing plants
that's
not that i mean yeah that's like it's
they're okay it's like different lettuce
it's
it's it's like a candle it's like those
candles that have a ring in
in the bottom when you melt the candles
it's like a sticky novelty type type of
thing it's cool once or twice
but the way that you're describing it
now i think precon i think what you're
really good at is something
i'm not as good at which is like
you're really good at breaking your
frame and like changing i don't know if
i'm even phrasing this correctly but
kind of changing the whole paradigm
which is like
no no we're gonna build the largest farm
in the world and now when you say that i
think
man so you're just gonna have to buy all
this land and have this massive huge
feel
but you're kind of saying like oh but by
the way by farm
i mean it's like these little small
things in every convenience store in
america
do you know what i mean yeah and uh that
that's kind of like
the trade-off here which is you know a
farm
that's like maybe you know in a 50 000
square foot building
that might be like you know thousands or
tens of thousands of
like land acres that you're replacing
because vertical farming does many
things it reduces the water but it also
compacts
how much space you need to do the action
so instead of buying large masses of
land
to produce this you can buy warehouses
or facilities
closer to the city center and serve that
area right and so
if you can be near like a city like
austin or san francisco
you can kind of serve that city kind of
efficiently with kind of a smaller you
know kind of smaller
brilliant yeah that's so cool and dude
like i think what you're really good at
like
when i'm around you i feel so inspired
and i want to bring something up in a
second that's related to this but
basically like
you are the type of i hate when we talk
about san francisco it's this lovely
place everyone needs to go
but the type of people like you there
was a large density of that in san
francisco and i am not at all naturally
like you
but i felt i improved and just changed
my opinion
on so many things after hanging out with
people like you i don't know what we
call that
i think sean is a little bit more like
you than than i
am but we we also have a handful of
friends that are like that and they just
like
you guys think about stuff in such a way
where
maybe it's like when i asked some when i
asked my challenge myself to come up
with an idea or think about what's the
possibility of x y and z
i put these constraints on where like um
well there's no way i could pull off
this because
that technology for this doesn't work or
i'm not good enough to do this or but
that's it's always been done x
um whereas when you think of stuff
you're really good at being open-minded
and defaulting to like well let's
actually that is kind of interesting
let's play that out
and you don't have these constraints of
like being held back
that a lot of normal people like me have
i think do you know what i mean sean
yeah um i i think it's simpler than that
i think fer khan is
you know everybody uses their own frame
of reference their own lens
and uh he looks at things through the
lens of a technologist so i think
and i i remember sitting down next to
you and being like how did you
get the way you are and you're like well
like i remember when i was five my dad
bought home brought home like a printer
and like we put it together
right wasn't that the story like a
computer or a printer when you're like
five or six years old
yeah since my earliest memories it was
an xt computer it was kind of like
you know not even doss yet it was just
like a screen and uh
he put it together we booted it up and i
remember he had like a disc that had
you typed like auto exec i was just a
kid i knew how to type
a-u-t-o-e-x-e-c if i press enter
i get to this like simulation football
game and that's all i could do like you
pick a play and it runs it for you you
don't even
you don't even actually play the game
but like i remember that as the earliest
memories and
i mean i got started really young like i
worked at a.com when i was 15 and
just like my my hobbies ended up being
very valuable like i wasn't a
you know not a musician where you know i
would have had it made it really big it
was like
i was into computers and programming and
doing things like that and
uh those things just happened to have
become very valuable
especially in the bay area and that that
kind of like lended itself to a lot of
opportunities
also something that you're gonna do with
this what do you what are you calling
your space
again uh we call it founders inc that's
like the company name
so i i want to like tell a quick story
about that so
back in 2000 and sean i can't see your
face so i can't see if you're i can't
tell if you're on board with this story
but
uh you back in 2013 so basically
sean why didn't you start as the monkey
inferno uh like the guy inside
joined uh at the end of 2012 so
basically 2013 is kind of the actual
beginning
so around that time i was working out of
that i was i just sold something and i
didn't make
a lot of money but like 100 grand let's
say and i was looking to start something
else and i found this guy named dave
and he had a thing called founders dojo
which was basically
he rented an office it would he i don't
know dave had a business that probably
did
half a million in sales and he probably
profited 400 000 so he wasn't a
rich rich guy but he had this office
that he could spend 3k on
a month and he let me and like eight
other people
come and work out of his office and he
uh we heard about it through friends of
friends like hey there's a thing called
founder dojo they're letting like
people just work there and it's a dingy
office it wasn't nice it was maybe
six 500 square feet and then down the
street was the same thing but it was far
fancier it was called monkey inferno it
was pretty much the exact same thing but
like way better it was this guy named
michael burch who was on the podcast if
you look up the hippie
who made a billion dollars that sean did
that episode and it was a guy who
started and sold the company for
hundreds of millions or close to a
billion dollars and his like project was
the same exact thing it was nicer you
know they had like
you guys probably had like hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of interior
decorating and
uh it was like really fancy but it was
the same thing basically of like
nerds and like weirdos and misfits we
all would come to these spaces and i
would hang out monkeying for it all the
time and you guys sometimes came to
our thing and we would we would dork out
to the stuff that people would make fun
of like dave
loved meerkat meerkat was uh basically
a live streaming app which kind of like
was the early technology and early
behavior for
even like a like a clubhouse or whatever
um and he would do this thing called a
marathon he called it and he would
meerkat for 24 hours straight he would
be in the office
mere catting for 24 hours straight and
he would meet these other dorks and they
would come and fly into our office
and then um it was just so weird like we
did all this weird [__] one time we
created this thing called uh what do we
call it
uh coffee coffee rush we called it and
you click a button and you get coffee
inside like
20 minutes wherever you are in san
francisco and all these just nerdy dorky
little projects but it was like the best
time of my life
and it was the most one of the most
formative it was some of the best
experiences i ever had as it relates to
business and just like becoming a man
and like
tinkering with all these new things and
having an open mind and i think what
you're setting up for con is like the
next
obviously this is like the next
iteration of that and i'm so fortunate
that i've had people like you and
uh and you guys have birch michael burch
and i had dave grossblatt
i'm so fortunate that people like you
guys exist in this world because these
little silly things
that like are fun and like that seems
stupid on the outside and the fact that
there's these
grown adults who are thankfully wealthy
enough and willing to bet their money to
do this stuff
it sounds outrageous and it sounds like
a movie and i'm so happy i was part of
it and it made such a huge difference
um it's like the fact that these exist
it's a movie 100
and uh those places you talk about so i
know david grossblatt as well
and uh you know i used to go to another
place growing up hacker dojo
it was mountain view and uh you know
even growing up in silicon valley you
didn't immediately have like a network
like i don't know
like a bunch of vcs just from growing up
here that's not actually not how it
worked
my block didn't have vcs on it it was
just normal people and uh
you know you really didn't find people
like yourself and so the internet
changed a lot right like it allowed
people to connect with each other and
find each other but you know the
in-person interactions
they just operate differently and it's a
lot more ad hoc like i remember you
being at the monkey inferno and
a lot of other you know people that we
would have work out of there
it was cool because you could just walk
by break up a random conversation
talk about something and maybe it
resulted in nothing and sometimes it
would actually
stick with you and it would be really
important and so um
at applovin it felt the same way early
on when we were kind of doing these like
you know random ideas it was like
oh we're just a bunch of misfits
together here that are just going to go
on this journey and
that energy is just hard to replace and
it was really fun and every time it's
been there it's been really instrumental
for me and
like learning a lot like conversations
during the lunch table at monkey inferno
shaped a lot about
how people think what are you know what
are ways to conduct yourself like just
things even outside of tech right like
you interact
with a lot of different people and you
can bring good energy to it and uh i
think it's really critical and so i've
been on this mission
slightly before kova to kind of like
build this facility but then
kind of covet happened and you know
obviously like it's good in terms of
like
new buildings new opportunities cheaper
rent here in the city great
but i think this thing is kind of
necessary for a lot of people
who are in this builder phase you know
like they might not be a founder yet
they might not go raise a bunch of money
they just want to build some stuff and
hack on it and i'm willing to kind of
take a bet to build that facility and on
this podcast we talk a ton about like
buying businesses
and we almost get to the point where it
almost sounds like we're a bunch of like
uh banker pe types where it's like oh
this is
an interesting opportunity but the
coolest [__] that i've ever done and the
most fun i've ever done
is just dorking out with like people
that were
like me and just like oh this is kind of
funny like this is silly like we could
do that
it all starts like this is so stupid
it's so fun and
sometimes it like turns into really cool
amazing stuff and and i think that
that's fun to remember that that should
that should that should be how a lot of
stuff starts or um
maybe like maybe it's not should be but
it can be that way which is i think
better
yeah organic organic is awesome right it
just means that we just kind of sat
around we brainstormed some ideas some
of our experiences we tried some things
uh you need to be able to try things i
think that's like really important and
if i can reduce uh you know for me
growing up i didn't have a lot of like
people that i could lean on that's like
they had done this already or they were
doing businesses it was just like
kind of fail as you go take a bunch of
scars
and uh you know finding like people like
adam and sean like was critical for me
in the sense that like i had
people that i could talk to about
business things that like maybe other
people
i couldn't interact with and i just want
to kind of if i can take that
for let's say like sean said earlier uh
you know myself 15 years ago
i could give myself some of that like
that's what i that's what i feel like
i'm
kind of building over here yeah there's
what's that cheesy phrase that's
great but cheesy it's like be the person
you needed
when as you know when you're a kid or
something like that uh it's one of those
things that like if everybody actually
did it you know the world would sort of
be a good great place
um and and i think that's what in many
ways you're doing
uh i don't know what i needed i i sort
of like had a different journey where i
was like
just kind of on autopilot for like 20
years uh didn't
have an entrepreneurial bone in my body
uh didn't
think about stuff i just kind of was
going with the flow pretty like
you know i was trying to try to do good
at school but i was okay it wasn't
wasn't the best
wasn't particularly a hard worker wasn't
doing anything interesting
wasn't great you know socially and i
just felt like i kind of woke up when i
was 21 years old it started
you know when i had my first idea for a
company that's when i started to be more
like me and so
i think everybody you know okay why do i
do this podcast
well i'm not going to say i do it to
give back like that's not why i do it
because it's fun
but the side effect of doing it is that
the person who's me when they're 18 17
20 years old or 30 doesn't even matter
how old if you're kind of in that
autopilot phase where you don't feel
like you found
your thing or you don't feel like you
know you're excited every day to wake up
then all of a sudden you hear a couple
guys on a podcast shooting the [__] they
sound really excited about life they got
great energy
they get ideas for days and you start to
look at yourself like why don't i see
ideas all the time
how are these guys able to come on the
podcast two times we can do it and so
what does that do it proliferates more
people
that are like me that's you know what i
want you know i i am the way i want to
be
so that hopefully i can like you know
incept a bunch of other people in their
brain that maybe they can
pick that up right podcast a vehicle to
do that you're doing the same thing
you know when you were growing up you
were you know messing around with
hardware and cars and
uh business when you were 15 16 years
old and you were just messing around
with computers and so and
a bunch of people helped you out right
your dad bringing home the computer or
i think you told me about a guy kind of
in your neighborhood who had like the
car
stuff that you could use to go work on
cars if you didn't have that hardware
and you picked up those hobbies and you
just followed those hobbies you double
down triple down
even though that wasn't the common path
right the common path was
finish college get a job like get
married have kids whatever right like
everybody has this like
path that's kind of like your parents
and society sort of
throws at you and you went off that path
i think when you went off that path
you probably didn't have as much
guidance as like you're able to provide
to that next wave where
they should go on to do bigger and
better things because you know you're
able to knock down a few of those walls
for them or with them
yeah and uh i i like how you phrased it
uh the cheesy phrase is
obviously interesting but like i don't
think giving back is the right
that's not the right way to frame this
because it's like it's not charity right
like obviously like
i'm building a business i do believe in
the long run uh i want to make money
with this business and then things i'm
gonna invest in
are gonna in the long run pay off for me
monetarily as well but
as a side effect uh i i do believe that
you know kind of like your podcast like
you're gonna inspire a lot of people i
would love to inspire the next like
thousand builders
or founders kind of however you wanna
phrase it and
i think that side effect is fantastic i
don't think that business has to be
you know detached from you know some
side effect like
i think it's if i wanted to make it a
charity i'd make it a non-profit right
like that would be the way to go and
that would be kind of the way to do it
but i think there's a lot of benefit and
a lot of people will benefit hopefully
from it and
ideally not just because of me like
hopefully it's more like
i don't know what the discord has become
it's like founders helping each other
like that's the best
version of this and if i could be maybe
the person that can first create the
circle
then awesome like that would be the hope
over here what's the biggest kind of
like common mistake or trap you're
seeing
when you have those kind of young
entrepreneurs in the discord working on
their projects
what is the advice you keep on giving
over and over again that like
you feel like is the common the common
mistakes the common traps that they're
falling into
i think it's always you know what are
you focused on so like
if you're a builder you're probably
spending a lot of your energy on
building
and if you're you know really most of
these companies will
kind of die in the market not attack and
there's some challenges sometimes but
even as a technology person i would not
spend too much time on technology
and sean you experienced this firsthand
like how many times was i like we'll
just hack it in and all the engineers
are like
cringe right it's like well we have to
like we need to go win this market or
figure out if this is real or not if
it's not real
we need to move on from this very fast
because we're just wasting time money
energy and probably your company
if we go down the wrong path here and so
it's pretty much always focused on
you know for me a lot of the advice is
like go be more aggressive on growth
go figure out your market go understand
your customers
use technology as a weapon for that not
it's not the purpose that you're
building like you're going to sit here
build this technology somebody else is
going to go take your market
probably with the same technology by the
way sam i don't know if you have a hard
stop but
there's one other one that i think is is
interesting that uh furkan could talk
about i don't know if you can talk about
it but pac protocol or
yeah i don't know can you talk about
that or is either that or i think you
know the way you're setting up the dow
or any dowser you're a part of i think
are interesting so
pick one of those two and then talk
about that yeah so uh
you know dow decentralized autonomous
organization i'll call it a
decentralized org it's a little bit
simpler to understand
is really just kind of like this thing
happening in the crypto world where
um people are forming effectively these
partnerships together
they're doing it on you know on chain
meaning as like an actual
organization that kind of owns this code
and things like that
and so so let me let me simplify for a
second so
sam and you started the hustle you
probably made a delaware c-corp
right so you go to delaware that's the
rule of law that's kind of where you're
going to go write down all your articles
of incorporation
and you chose c-corp as the like
structure of your organization
and that lets you do certain things you
could take investment you could do this
you could do that
and so you could do an llc you could do
a s-corp you could do it in nevada you
could do in california
so those are the current ways that you
start when you have a project where you
need a bunch of people to work together
and be financially incentivized as a
group
you you traditionally you would use you
know a delaware c-corp or
llc or something like that so what he's
providing what he's talking about is
an alternative that's been made and i i
think forgot the trick here is
what do they let you do that's different
than just making it why why don't i just
go to an llc or a c corp
uh in delaware well it lets you first be
um you know it lets you kind of
detach yourself from the legal entity
and how you were kind of like having
your stake of ownership
and kind of voting and governance of the
company so like
you know we talked a lot sean before of
like man it kind of sucks companies are
like
top heavy and everybody's putting a lot
of energy and effort and
yeah you might need a person that's
responsible for making these choices but
wouldn't it be cool if and you know a
bunch of people on the internet
basically
took that wouldn't it be cool if we made
a company that could be owned by
everybody equally
and he could do things like voting or
managing the treasury or
issuing new you know tokens or shares to
people
and you could incentivize them however
you wanted so like if you bring on some
people to help you market and like some
let's say a big celebrity
you can issue some governance to them
like they could be a part of this you
can align incentive between
investors founders community the market
whoever you want and so here's an
example of one right that you've showed
me
so there's this thing called the lao
have you ever heard of this sam so the
lao
lao what it is is it's a venture fund
but instead of
um like if you go to sequoia sequoia's
got you know let's say the gps the
general partners
it's got the managing director maybe and
it's got then the associates and the
analysts it's like a
traditional company it's like a pyramid
at the top is the people in charge
and what the dow is is basically here's
a fund
you put your money in for however much
money you put in you get certain number
of tokens
tokens are like shares and uh and then
there's nobody specifically in charge
and
the fund basically can receive proposals
so there's just they have a website
you can pitch them the pitch goes in
everybody gets it in their inbox
everybody votes yes or no based on how
many tokens they hold
that's their vote that's their weight
and then if the majority of the dow has
voted yes
it gets the treasury which is the bank
account for the for the for the lao
will pay out that project here's your
investment and uh
and then at any time i if i don't like
the lao i can just sell my steak
sell it to anybody else they could take
my spot and allow um
and you know now they own they have that
chair so it's completely liquid at all
times
whether there's maybe there's been great
projects in there and now these things
looked really valuable these tokens
look more valuable than the initial
money that was put in
well i can sell out i don't have to wait
10 years for those projects to pan out i
can sell out today
at two that double my money or um
you know i can say i wanna i wanna have
more control i'm gonna buy
out more tokens so that i have a greater
say in this community because i'm
gonna spend a bunch of time and i really
wanna make sure my my vote matters and
basically it ties your vote
to your sort of your merits how much
value you put in
in this case how much money you put into
the lao so they did it as an investment
vehicle
other people did it as an art collecting
vehicle put money in
buy art art is owned by the group and
you could sell in
in whatever so there's these uh headless
companies there's no ceo in a suit at
the top
that is telling everybody what to do and
deciding who gets hired and fired
it's just a bunch of shareholders
together and you vote based on your
shares it's like
you know more like america like a
democracy i guess and then yeah
there's other variations of that too
that i can't even wrap my head around
those are the simple ones i've
understood there's others that i don't
even understand yet yeah
it's it's very complicated very very
complex but the
simple version i like how you phrase it
is kind of like a democracy times a
company
uh you know mixed in one and maybe
companies even the wrong phrasing there
but
you know i'm very fascinated with this
it's a very different pattern
i don't know if it's better or worse
than you know what we've seen
traditionally but it's definitely
different right and uh
i've been wanting to kind of like you
know be a part of one create one and so
i joined a couple but i'm not like you
know some meaningful stakeholder in it
but then you know with a lot of the work
that's been going on in nfts a lot of
popularity
the top shot is just like taking over
like my friends group and uh
very popular and i know you're super
into like bitcloud and some of these
other
uh platforms and so i've been wanting to
kind of
wrap my head around nfts and i started
talking to a lot of developers and
people that are interested about
some of these ideas that i had and i
found like a group of five six people
that
i'm like oh we're we're all kind of
really into this let's make a dow
i'll like kind of put in the first
amount of money and now a couple of my
buddies are also
putting in some money for getting some
stake in this and the idea is we're just
going to be kind of a group of people
that are going to build fun
projects in the nft space and our goal
is
there's a lot of hype right now we're in
that hype cycle life cycle is going to
go away right it's the same pattern that
we talked about before
well what is the valuable things that
nfts can do
let's go build some of these and so you
know we have two ideas that we're
working on right now as a group
one of them is like shopify for nfts
like you come in you click two buttons
and you like
you can create your own and you know
i'll ask you this john like you've heard
a lot about nfts you've talked a lot
about him
have you minted your own yet i have not
why not uh i don't know what the hell
my nft would be so like for example we
have a friend
jack butcher who has minted many nfts
now himself
and he's a great designer so he makes
like a cool visual
it's like badass art and he's like oh
cool instead of just posting this for
free on twitter for likes
i'll post this on foundation and i'll
sell it and he sold some of these for 60
000 each um and so he's made you know a
lot of money this year just basically
selling
his own kind of like his philosophies he
just makes into a kind of a digital
poster
and he sells that digital poster to his
fans and so
for me i'm like oh that's cool if i made
an nft i don't know i don't have that
artistic skill i don't even know what
the actual nft would be that's kind of
my thought and then but you haven't even
just
tried one right like when you first saw
shopify you went and created a store
right like
you didn't you didn't have to start a
company you know or sell something but
you wouldn't do it one's easier than the
other one you're typing in a user fake
new username and password
yeah exactly i mean if i open the
shopify store i also need to put a
product there right like
i can't also have a yeah you can you can
try
that's the thing that i saw is like a
lot of this uh these worlds defy nfts
the dollar value is really big at the
top end of it when you go and dig
underneath and you're like ah there's
only like 5 000 users doing this why is
it so little right
and there's a lot of interest in doing
it really hard to do
and i believe that's like one of the
biggest opportunities in nfts is just
like
make make it really easy for people to
do it
almost as easy as creating a shopify
store so that's like project idea one
like
we're gonna basically pay for your gas
we're gonna make it so you can deploy
your own contract without ever thinking
about it
you're gonna just click a couple buttons
and get a landing page that you can send
to people
and they can buy stuff digitally okay
we're gonna make it literally
that easy so that's i think that's like
accessibility really important
um second one which is the thing you
were talking about which is the pax
protocol like
you know there's building products and
then there's building protocol
and protocols are just like here's an
api to go do this thing
and nba top shot i mean probably one of
the biggest
digital products we've seen since
pokemon go
i'll kind of call it that like that wave
of like hype
you know reaching some mass market um
a lot of interest in it uh but it's very
close right i mean you have to be an nba
player to get one you have to
kind of like be in the nba you got to
play in this whole ecosystem and
you know who knows what they're going to
be worth in the long run but in the
short run there's a lot of interest
there but only the nba is doing it
you'll see the other sports teams do it
and but the basic idea of creating a
pack
with some digital items in it or
potentially kind of linking to the real
world
that's kind of what i got really excited
about and so we you know as part of nft
labs we created this
axe protocol which is a protocol to
create
kind of a you know like a little loot
box pack where you can put in digital
items and you could put in
an image a sound clip for like let's say
your guys podcast
or you know kind of access like hey
here's a ticket to
a vip event that i'm gonna do here or
there's a meet and greet or here's my
private community and so
creators are gonna find a lot of ways to
use this if we develop that underneath
foundation
that they can kind of do all this and so
so sam does that make sense of how
so like for example what we would do is
we would say oh cool these guys built
the infrastructure that makes it easy
for us to do the following
we can create these little packs meaning
like a card pack or like a box like a
loot box
and basically you put it's a mystery box
you don't know what's inside
so you buy one you open it up and you're
gonna get one you know maybe you get the
crap or maybe you get the most vip thing
where
sam calls you and coaches you on your
business for an hour and what's that
called what's the
what's the domain so nft labs dot co
is kind of like the main domain so
that's where
that's one of their projects and so i
think this is pretty cool because
they're going to be able to get any
like influencer like us and so there's
one thing to do with jax doing which is
and actually jack did this i don't know
if you saw this uh furcon but he
initially was selling a specific nft hey
buy this thing
and then he sold three packs with inside
was a mystery
nft he didn't know what he was gonna he
made many six figures i believe yeah and
like this mechanic
many many games use these like loot box
mechanics because it's fun it's fun to
go buy the thing and see
do you get the super rare valuable thing
or did you get kind of the junk
and you know you so you either get you
know 60 cents on the dollar or you get
60 for every dollar you spent and
there's like this game of chance
and so what they're doing is they made a
protocol where it's now easy for us to
do
that we could make all these packs we
could put inside hey tickets to our live
show in austin or
you know you get to be put into our like
private members group or here's a
t-shirt
you know with our you know here's a
harvard shirt whatever um
and so we could put any number of things
just stuff them into boxes and assign
some probability
and then it'll generate the packs for us
which i think is pretty sweet
yeah and uh you know like i really just
think a lot about like
what what's the value underneath it like
we have to get to you know
i mean art has value you know obviously
the person buying it cares about it but
a lot of people look at that and go wait
you know these things are selling for
like 50 million bucks plus and like
what's the you know it's just a jpeg
underneath but like i mean a vip meet
and greet when you guys do your road
show
that's pretty cool actually and i think
a lot of people would be really excited
about it
it sucks if you only auction that off to
the you know person who has the most
money
right like and i think these packs give
kind of the you know
creators and influencers a way to
interact with their fans kind of more
broadly and say
all of you guys will get a chance and
here's kind of the things of it by the
way
you know if there were only 10 vip meet
and greets we'll make the third party
marketplace like top shop or if somebody
wants to go spend 100 grand for it
by the way you guys will earn a cut of
that secondary sale
plus somebody who got that if they
didn't want it and they wanted to sell
it they can kind of do that and so
you can support both sides of the
ecosystem you can make it
kind of fan friendly but then you can go
kind of get a lot of value out of it too
and so
i don't know i find creators really
interesting because they're kind of an
analogy to founders where
you know i don't want to go work at a
fan company i mean you you know i i made
it through twitch but
it was not it's not the right
environment right like it's not where
i'm gonna thrive it's not where i'm
gonna be excited
and i think creators have the same thing
i saw a great idea on this uh the
founder of ripplet
uh uh tweeted this out he goes there's a
bunch of people who
engineers who work at like fang
companies they make great salaries
and they kind of want they're kind of
bored they want to go to a startup but
the like
the compensation difference is pretty
big and maybe they have a family or they
just
you know it's just hard to walk away
from a guaranteed you know
five hundred six hundred thousand
dollars a year to go work for
one-fifth that or one-fourth that at a
startup that may or may not make it
and he goes somebody should just create
a fund that just bridges the difference
so what it does is it basically says
great we will um
we'll even out that difference so you
get 300 instead of let's say 600
and it's an income share agreement and
but you pay us back with your with stock
from the from the startup
and so you give up a little bit of the
stock from the startup to make back the
cash difference and in doing so you
would create a port
so you would it would help more people
who today can't leave the
salary go to a startup you'd help the
startup not have to
burn more money hiring that person and
and use it in between and by providing
that
you would get shares in pretty much
every startup that you wanted to provide
this with so if you say you thought
these 100 startups are great you could
basically say great you're all eligible
for this
this like kind of like income share
agreement that we do where
if you hire somebody and they want a bit
higher salary we'll front that salary
in exchange for stock um and hopefully
bring more talent into the startup
workforce i thought that was a pretty
clever idea
a way to get shares in all the companies
that you want shares in that you can't
go invest in directly
yeah that's really interesting and uh i
don't know i think people should just
you know ideally people can do the thing
that they enjoy they wake up every day
they're excited whether they gotta drive
to work or work from home or wherever it
is
uh if you can do that like that that's a
big unlock in your life and a lot of
people don't get that opportunity and
early on in my career i just made those
trades like kind of no matter how
financially painful or you know
you know misguided it might have seemed
at the time but like i just wanted to
work on things that i was excited about
and when you and everyone went to loving
when you went to top 11 you had another
job offer right
uh what was the difference there yeah so
i
had met this guy jack levin i think he
was like you know very early at google
he was responsible
for um you know kind of a lot of
google's infrastructure tricks early on
like how they really scaled it and
some of the ways they win is really his
responsibility and he
was working on this company i think it
was called why frog was it was like a
photo sharing type thing i think they
had run another product
i think it was photo bucket something
like that they had done some big stuff
in the photo space
they were doing really well they needed
some engineers uh i was an engineer at
the time
and i could basically come in and learn
a lot from this very technical person
um seemed really sharp uh he asked me
these questions that like got my brain
going in a good way like
you know very specific questions like
how do you set up your desktop
and like my desktop is very particular
and he wanted to know every detail
and i was like ah this guy gets it like
this guy gets me in the same way
um then i met adam and adam was like
very different
uh obviously very impressive as just a
ceo and a person but like
the conversation was different the vibe
was different one was in like los gatos
one was in palo alto just like a little
bit of a different area but
when i talked to adam i was like oh this
guy i could go to a baseball game with
him i could hang out with
him he seems cool he seems very hungry
they don't have a clue what they're
doing right now like you know they're
shutting down an idea they don't know
what the next idea necessarily is gonna
be
i think it's gonna be a lot more fun the
rate of learning is gonna be really high
i might get more responsibility but the
really good like kind of proper choice
was
going to this other job offer and adam
gave me two options he gave me a higher
salary and a low stock and
a lower salary and a higher stock option
and i was like i kind of just made the
decision down to like
well if i go with you know adam i need
to take the low salary
move back in with my parents like take
the stock because like i'm gonna be
in it for the ride but if i just kind of
want to become an engineer and that's
what i want my career to be
i'm gonna go to this other company i'm
gonna take the salary i'm not worried
about the equity necessarily how big
that is but i'm just gonna
become a better engineer and uh i kind
of picked
the more unknown less uh polished option
uh obviously worked out so i feel great
about it but you took the move in with
the parents option
and yeah it took the move in with the
parents in a absurd way
yeah how old are you when you started uh
at app11 um let's see
probably like 25 26
no moving moving at home wasn't the
worst but yeah it wasn't good
maybe a little bit yeah 26 that's maybe
just old enough where it's kind of like
all right what are you doing but
definitely not quite inconvenient
socially
yeah okay when you move out
right so you move out of your house and
you move back in it's not like a happy
like uh yeah i'm winning high fives all
around right
yeah like no no i mean like you um
you're like in your 30s or like you have
a family like
if you're happy you're like a little
more established yeah okay yeah 26 is
old enough that it's still
like you can still [__] around and maybe
figure it out which you did
uh yeah and you know what i mean you
know i think you'll almost be a kid
yeah exactly i i think for me it was
just like i know i wanted to do this it
sounded more fun more fun is always good
uh you're gonna be you're gonna wake up
you're gonna be excited to go to work
it's not gonna be a drag
like you know i would tell sean this all
the time because we used to do sunday
night call
right where we would kind of think about
the week and it was like my friends were
always sunday night like oh man work
tomorrow
like sunday like sucks like weekends
over and i
always felt like hey it's exciting like
more stuff's gonna happen
this week's gonna be great like and
that's a big difference if more people
can do that like that
that i think is uh when we did those
sunday calls
i remember i'd always be like oh like
sorry i gotta like i'm doing this thing
with family or friends or whatever i'm
like
i gotta go get on this call and they're
like oh man you have to do calls on
sunday nights and i was like
i get to do calls like i'm i chose this
i want to do this
i can't wait for monday we got to do it
tonight you know that was our mindset
and like
you know we didn't have as like
spectacular of an outcome but i
definitely had like a spectacular time
building that out and learning all the
different stuff so anyways i think
that's
that's if you take away one thing like
maybe you didn't understand the
technology but like
the meta lesson of furcon to me is he
always picked the more fun and
interesting path
regardless of the financial thing and
then on the financial side just made
sure that it was
a bet on himself and a bet on equity so
that if fun and interesting thing does
pan out you actually do get paid out of
it
and i've seen him make that trade of
like i'll work harder i'll earn less
i'll move back in with my parents
i'll you know all these things right
like he's willing to work three times as
hard as long as it's three times as fun
and i think most people at least from
where i come from they don't do that
they when they make career choices it's
a rational
logical decision and i think that gets
you to a certain type of outcome
but if you hear these outcomes and
you're like how do i get some of that i
think you got to follow the irrational
playbook a bit more
i mean sean if you look across your
journey at monkey inferno i mean you're
a 24
year old pretty pretty green right like
i
think i saw your initial video interview
that you had sent in
uh through the monkey inferno and like
uh
whether the dollar outcome was there or
not like i would say the rate of
learning like the growth
difference for you and i know for that
for myself it's a massive difference
like
i'm embarrassed at what i used to think
about back then in terms of building
compared to kind of after the journey
but you'd feel like that was like a
thousand next payoff and the rest of
your career is gonna kind of unlock
because of it right like i
i would imagine you believe that but i'm
curious how you think about that journey
yeah 100
i i told the guys who set up our studios
this
and um i mentioned this on a recent
podcast but i said
they came they they flew out here to san
francisco they were like staying in a
motel six type of thing they're like i'm
gonna build this out
and um you know they're 22 23 24 years
old something like that
and they had sent in a video like kind
of like a video interview to be like sam
sean
choose us to like like we will help you
guys out we will come build your studio
for you they've like did a ballsy
youtube video and tweeting at us like
non-stop [__] i used to do i used to
wait in parking lots
to meet ceos and investors i wanted to
meet just so i could say i've been here
since 7 00 am
waiting in the parking lot for you to
come out like do you have five minutes
of time right i used to do all these
stunts
and they were doing a stunt to meet us
and i thought that was kind of
interesting and when they were there i
was like
uh they kind of were like deferring to
me too much they were sort of like
it's kind of like too much respect and i
told him i was like
dude you you kind of want what i have i
want what you have i want
that time back and i want to be back
where you guys are where it's for
friends living in a
one-bedroom apartment and you're making
videos and you kind of like why are we
trying to be youtubers i don't know it
seems fun let's just do it
and then like we think these guys have a
cool podcast [__] it let's fly out and
meet them and help them out with their
studio and
we don't know what's you know there's no
there's nothing clearly in it for us but
like
we'll hop on that plane tomorrow and go
make it happen i told him i said
that was by far the most fun time um
there was the highest rate of learning
and i remember at the time feeling like
oh man like everything we do is so
bootleg and ghetto and like but that was
the right path
actually for me for a person like me who
wanted what i wanted out of life and i
said
you're gonna i remember you know i went
to duke most of my friends went to med
school law school or
banking or consulting and so every you
know every weekend they would post
like they're you know they're making six
figures they're posting themselves at a
bar they're like
like i wasn't dating i had no income i
was sleeping on an air mattress you know
you know
my my co-founder lived in my closet
right so it was like you know it was
ghetto and so
i remember thinking well uh maybe
you know there was moments of doubt
where i was like maybe i should have
gone the traditional path maybe i should
have gone to med school after all
but uh but it was so fun i couldn't you
know i didn't there was not a real
conversation in my head
what i was telling these guys was yo uh
you're gonna see your friends who are on
the traditional path and they're going
to look like they're way far ahead of
you right now and there's going to be a
part of you who feels like you're
you're left behind uh if you're like me
that's what i felt
um stay the path and just know that like
this is the first quarter we're going to
be long-term oriented
we're gonna think about this like in a
10 20 year time scale
who do you want to be in 10 20 years and
like you're gonna have a lot of fun now
and then your rewards are gonna catch up
20 years from now and if you're okay
with that trade of having
more fun now and rewards that are a
little back loaded
this is the right path i wish somebody
had just told me at that time guys
this looks ghetto as hell but you're on
the right path um
we kind of just like for better worse
just stuck with it and i want more
people to stick with it when they're in
that mode and
you've done the same traveling through
europe playing poker to support yourself
and like you know moving back in with
your parents it's not a
it sounds at the time it feels uncommon
but it's actually quite common amongst
people who
end up successful in an entrepreneurial
way yeah flip side is just not easy
right you're gonna go the harder path
like you know i didn't i didn't have i
don't have a college degree i didn't get
that a lot of people ask me hey should i
go to college like i have these other
things going on and
you know like you don't have to you can
learn on your own especially now but
um it's definitely gonna be a harder
path don't expect linear returns where
if i put in
a year of work i get a year of kind of
success and then i put in five years of
work i get five years of success
it might be nothing for a long time and
you might kind of get it in the end but
i don't know the journey is very
exciting like that that that to me is
what matters because that's what you're
going to do every day you're going to
wake up every day and you're going to go
do this thing
are you excited about that and that's
kind of like critical yeah
thank you dude i always take a lot of
notes i'm taking notes now whenever you
come
i uh i'm excited for your success that's
so cool i um
thought app 11 was like this huge thing
whenever it was supposed to sell
a year or whatever a few years ago now
and then now
seeing what it is now i'm like oh my
gosh that's that's it's
it's blew my expectations i'm sure it is
uh yours as well so congratulations
that's pretty badass and what you're
building is awesome founders inc that's
badass
yeah sweet no appreciate it and uh yeah
no this has been fun
uh i always like hearing you guys so
it's kind of fun to be on as well and
where do you shoot the [__] a little bit
where do people find you founders inc or
founders.inc
yeah f dot inc uh that's the website and
so that's the domain
uh you can find me on twitter fur con r
uh
are f-u-r-q-a-n-r [__] on thanks for
coming
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off on the road less travel
never looking back